une dépêche d'amman jordanie nous
apprend que le conseil des ministre
jordanien a décidé ce soir de rompre les
relations diplomatiques avec la tunisie
sans prendre parti bien entendu sur les
raisons qui ont conduit le gouvernement
dahmane à cette initiative
nous voudrions repasser sur votre écran
un court extrait de l'interview que le
président tunisien a donné la semaine
dernière à christian brincourt et que
vous avez vu ici même dans l'extrait que
nous avons choisi le président bourguiba
parlait de lingettes l'ouest ce qui
n'existe pas en réalité c'est la
jordanie où la transjordanie qui n'ont
jamais existé dans l'histoire
transjordanie jordanie c'est le journal
simple une invention de l'angleterre
n'est ce pas pour contenter pour
consoler le prince l'émir abd allah et
en faire un trône qu'elle est l'amie du
royaume transjordanie comme on peut dire
le transmit du parti pour une grande
partie de l'egypte et on deale transmis
le trans aubrac à latence frati en
réalité de tout temps de planter quitté
depuis les philistins tiens ça vient de
définir le mot palestine
il y à une palestine qui va des
frontières que la de l'egypte aux
frontières du cham cham c'est à dire la
syrie liban et la palestine ce qui est
un pays qui a été peuplée qui était
connue depuis l'antiquité
mais la jordanie où l'attend
journalistes c'est une invention dans
l'hôtel et
et la guerre des six jours n'est ce pas
un roi de jordanie actuel où son
prédécesseur qui a décidé sans le
consentement des palestiniens d'annexer
la palestine comme les rayons un
excellent autres partis jeudi que nous
faut revenir à la réalité
reality ce qu'il y a une grande promesse
de palestine qui a été divisée par l'onu
pour accorder aux juifs un rom national
uni solaire sécurité à l'abri des
pogroms l'espagne pour crématoire des
humiliations qu'ils ont connue en europe
et surtout en europe centrale et
orientale mais jamais dans le monde
arabe